[Musica]
sì però sti cazzi i ragazzi benvenuti a
questo noviglio sono fa vigente su
silent sul nyse oppure silent night 2
non lo so tanto ragazzi è un alpha
testing quindi la nostra non è neanche
il gioco ufficiale visto che le foglie
scompaiono nel mio pene proviamo a
vedere di che si tratta visto che credo
sia un horror dal nome perché gesù
cinque anni dopo cinque anni dopo cosa
non è successa group cazzo ragazzi
qualsiasi anno fosse cinque anni dopo
va bene perché c'è una tizia c'è una
tizia che si vede nell'ombra come mai
cos'è giorno a bello è partito così bene
ragazzi è in assoluto la partenza più
bella che io abbia mai visto in un
horror
a me però l'ombra c'è l'ombra c'è già
qualcosa già che ci siamo svegliati a
parte che di horror io vedo solo
l'arredamento della casa che cazzo ne
starò a farsi il bagno davanti alla
finestra non è proprio il massimo della
vita si vede anche mia nonna che stai
facendo il bagno dal balcone ancora l'ho
capito qual è il quale dovrebbe essere
il senso di sto video di bello il
lampadario robot è una figata
teo titi cioè che mi ha detto di
accendere la televisione 6 maria de
filippi atv l'ho pagata io l'accendo
quando caso voglio io
ma cosa fanno nella salsa di soia che
mettono al sushi qualcuno a del sushi
che io ho la salsa di soia
scherzavo vedo che la televisione già
accesa si può dire che sia accesa sei
uomini e donne ragazzi vogliamo uomini e
donne c'è un telecomando una vita meno
perché sennò la [ __ ]
[ __ ] ladra [ __ ] fermi tutti
c'era un tizio che è sparito e poi è
caduto lampada roba che faceva schifo
non è una gran perdita al lampadario va
bene così ma chi maria posso uscire
migliaccio la macchia alla scorta si sa
se io ti apro tu non ti chiudi perché
sennò ti apro anche la madre le porte
non sono più gentili come una volta
posso entrare
sì nel senso posso proprio proprio
entrare dentro la macchina senza neanche
aprire la portiera bellissimo gioco
dell'arma parte camminare dentro dentro
l'auto cosa fosse sembrati ball auto dei
flinstones che va a va a piedi
fantastico permesso a in cucina sono
stato attaccato da un porta uova se
qualcuno che mi ha parlato tipo 2
secondi e non ho capito chi fosse
marketing di più perché c'è del sangue
sulla mia porta ma maria maria sei tu
che cazzo di porte si aprono un po più
lentamente magari facciamoci la doccia
ragazzi tanto ci vedono tutti tranquilli
che poi è un gioco stranissimo perché
ciò delle cose fatte di merda ma al 33
fatti tipo il cesso e splendente grazie
alla porta tecnologica si apre la sorba
permesso ma c'è per caso la saponetta
che mi sapone i maroni non la saponetta
ciaoo ma voglio che ti battono 5 sia
vedi qua la doccia la politica sana
sporchi di sangue che scelse di m nello
spalmi per bene subito ai tool cazzi
tuoi poi ascolta signora guarda che
questa è casa mia non è che chiama
scritto sul muro bastardi uno ci mette
anni ab bianca a casa per questo mi
scrivono sul morale è una vera una
poesia ragazzi c'è scritto le rose sono
rosa le viole e son viola la doccia la
pulisce la signora quella di prima
ovviamente
[Musica]
anche a te ti amo tanto tota zia e
quello è il mio accesso magari faccia
anche brutta figura di melo ecco
spaventata questi discorsi senato ha sì
proprio portata via accesso a sconfitta
ti sei innamorata così tanto abbiamo
capito che il sesso piace c'è nel senso
al suo charme e va beh grazie che
sostenuto sono svenuto sulle scale a
caso la corea ma siamo tutti droghi ti
droghi pesante famme capì arrivo arriva
il parco di amazon che ho capito allora
è un sogno non svenire sentito qualcosa
mi dice che non è amazon ma è una bella
[ __ ] la porta e se fortuna che non
capitano tutti i giorni arrivo arrivo
salve si può già venuto forse è successo
oddio ma è fatta di plastica ma come una
barbie questo so io che gioco più
realistico del mondo donna in cucina
così sta svendendo ragazzini sa
prevedere una puntata di beautiful è
arrivata la tv che si guarda già cosa
voi cos'è nuova beh quando ti va bene è
tetro lo zio tutti i file i pasti che
c'è una tizia c'è una tizia che è brutta
ne va beh tanto cioè di mascara eyeliner
scusatemi volo di che se c'è anche slann
darman che facciano le interferenze a
caso sei un figo comunque fatelo dire è
la droga al giorno d'oggi è né ognuno fa
quel che vuole la sua vita ci
mancherebbe altro
salve
e per questo si di questo significa
perdere la testa variazione vero senso
della parola
mi scusi se lo ha disturbato signora
continui a fare dei bei disegni che sta
facendo molto belli questa ed ora
l'esploratrice tra l'altro questo che
comunque è un leone fatto meglio di come
lo fare io e ve lo dico ciao sono favino
no no no ma che cazzo e la fiera della
marionetta cazzo piangi scorsi c'è
qualcuno che sta piangendo lagalla
potete smettere di fasto casinò c'è una
nuda sta piangendo perché non trova il
reggiseno la persona nuda ti aiuta lo
zio favia trovare un regista in
attraverso lo cerchiamo insieme con
calma non piangere perché se piange e
non lo troviamo quello non mi vuoi fare
non mi fa il file pa lei che già nuda
caso ciao ragazzi e sfruttato una mano
dal muro
la ragazza a farmi l'attimo possono
darla io con l'avanti notizia cioè non
hanno però perché son pervertito è ma è
perché sono pervertito
sì faccio del sì vabbè è una morte è una
morte dolce molto dolce ho sempre
sognato di morire così va bene ragazzi
continuiamo che mi sembra una bella
giornata prima di finire nel trash broda
cinesi però stai calmo c'era veramente
fatemi capire se carta una porta e si è
attaccato all'altro muro devo entrare
nel muro sto entrando a caso vabbè tanto
c'era una tipa correzione di fuori
quindi non mi stupisco vi silence su
nyse f serio serio che problemi al
cervello anno quelli che hanno creato
sto gioco bello bene la verità di dio
rispetto grazie per avermi reso
partecipe di questo gioco della vita
produsse abb si chiama mera j.murray
perché c'è la gela fine quindi mera j
fammi capire con che lassativi prendi
prima di angola dove voglio saperne
invece al thanks to antiche e tron bonne
siccome troppo è supportato queste cose
va beh allora possiamo alta voglio
vedere anche il mio nome in mezzo a loro
perché ho supportato anch'io un gioco
dove si vedono alle persone con le zinne
munque troppo per l'amor di dio
no ragazzi concluso che visse non fate
domande perché non ho capito un barcone
che cazzo giocato sul portiamo i
capolavori videoludici moderni spero che
vi sia piaciuto e cosa sento se vi è
piaciuto al trattamento è un mi piace
anche la faccia di facebook e cavani
video trovate come sempre nella
descrizione sono sentiti che noi ci
vediamo un po sorrido belle ragazze il
telecomando ancora non funziona però
faccio finta che funzioni lo stesso da
ragazzi